en fait c'est le jeu c'est le jeu tout
simplement et chaque année les miss
gagne la même chose et voilà
moi je suis un petit peu d'accord avec
toi c'est comme si don à prendre au
lycée on disait pourquoi c'est l'agent
de choses je voulais donner cet exemple
dans les dents les trois émissions où il
ya des gains d'argent on va pas dire ok
on est encore vide où on est en pause
qu'ovide alors on va tous / 10 c'est la
même chose aussi faire un peu rêver les
gens est encore plus mr ansel anonyme à
la base c'est pas une star et il ya
plein de jeunes filles qui n'ont encore
jamais pris l'avion qui prennent l'avion
pour la première fois enfin cette année
elles sont à versailles est un habitué
des leçons dans des trucs paradisiaque
moi j'étais par exemple à cancun pas
versailles c'est magnifique je
connaissais un mec tu habitais là bas
[Rires]
chaque année donc les la gagnante par
exemple remporte la gagnante remporte le
voyage avec son accompagnant donc si
c'est à cancun elle remporte le voyage
accent accompagnant donc là j'espère que
ce sera pas juste un verre ça va c'est
ça c'est ça c'est une bonne avec
d'autres pays ou pas la balade à moi
j'avais remporté le voyage center parcs
bon bah oui ça think i lewis attaché e
sata choc
pardon ça ce choc que oui en fait oui
parce que je me dis 57 mille euros total
pendant que donc certes déjà locaux
vides en fait c'est respectueux envers
la commune mais c'est aussi et
respectueux envers les personnes ne sais
pas qui meurent de faim dans les rues
alors laissez la développer c'est mon
charmant je te dise il a parlé en fait
je trouve ça vraiment dommage dans le
sens où déjà mon sincèrement je trouve
que le principe du concours de beauté
c'est déjà quelque chose d'un petit peu
bête selon moi parce que du coup ça faut
des stéréotypes un peu de beauté sa
complexe ça fait complique et des
cabines mais c'est vrai nous regarde pas
comme ça mais en fait c'est pas je veux
dire donnait 57 mille euros juste une
femme parce qu'elle est belle et
intelligente
je trouve ça vraiment dommage dans le
sens où il y en a plein qui mériterait
d'avoir de la nourriture d'autres choses
en fait je tais le nom pêche quand vous
entendez ça parce que d'affilée vous
êtes une ancienne miss ça n'a juste rien
à voir effectivement moi si j'avais pas
été miss france je serais pas là
aujourd'hui donc ça m'a ouvert
si on s'était croisés si c'est moi de me
françois rétro c'est que même avec miss
france est sans travail
au bout d'un moment on fait non plus pas
le après midi il faut pas oublier que
pendant l'année miss france on gagne
aussi un salaire c'est un boulot de
dingue d'être miss france à ça va
paraître un monsieur qui ne dort pas
beaucoup se consacre six jours sur sept
on se réveille très tôt on est maquillée
tous les jours au bout d'un moment même
la peau vachin on se couche très tard on
est crevé on a un salaire et les fip
aussi le motiver et c'est le rêve de
princesse preuve une gamme des bijoux un
gars les voies d'une longueur de télé
voilà c'est beau c'est 'qui nicolas bon
après c'est gagnant gagnant c'est un
échange marché en disant que les et vous
faites la promotion des marques et à la
soeur voilà tout le monde s'y retrouve
donc c'est pas de l'argent cash qui est
dépensé pour fatigue qui a totalement
raison d'ailleurs sur ce qu'elle dit
mais sélection de marchandises s'est pas
fait au delà 6,6 et c'est le principe de
l'offre et web ça tellement des missions
dans lesquelles les candidats se donne
du mal
intellectuellement physiquement ils
gagnent rien du tout en question pour un
champion ils ont ils ont une vraie
qualité cd en gagne un pauvre
dictionnaire là y'a pas que la gagnante
qui a des cas des candidates ont des
cadeaux et moi pardon mais je trouve ça
honteux en termes de signal envoyé c'est
la génération instagram c zéro talent
plein de cadeaux sans rien faire sans
rire travailler et à cette fois c'est
vrai sont elles font rien à paris un bel